yo or gave a max and we just finished
cooking up all the tips you'll need to
set your taste buds to stuff including a
signature cocktail talk about that it's
not going to happen signature cocktail
know as professional man stylist gave
and I know that it's important to be as
knowledgeable in the kitchen as you are
in the bedroom all of that they say that
the fastest way to a man's heart is
through a stomach but when it comes to
women if you put a lot of wine in their
stomachs as fast as you can so whether
it's that new boss or that new lady our
dining & wine tips will have them eating
out of the palm of your lap
got your kitchen suits on guys great
because it's important to cook for the
job you want not the job you have the
first thing everyone needs when they get
in the door and before you talk to
anyone is a glass or four glass of wine
just to loosen up now it is important
when cracking a new bottle of vino to
let the bouquet breathe because when
you've got licorice tanukhs like you do
here there's gonna be some floral notes
and they will quickly remind you that
they cannot all be 82 shetow the lines
and if you do have to drink wine around
other people make sure that you're the
worst I think what Gabe is trying to say
is that we all could learn some more
about wine Gabe is learning very quickly
as a muscle memory
for tonight's meal we're making a
classic classic rack of lamb even though
this may seem very fancy this is
actually a dish that even a total
kitchen idiot like Gabe can prepare come
I prepare your face first things first
we have to butcher the meat really get
in there do this for about 45 more
minutes I already have one prepared and
boy does it look good now I put this in
the oven why don't you set the table
game oh yeah if it's time to set the
table you're getting a sentra cocktail
I'm going to show you how to make the
ultimate Gabe teeny first you need three
parts vodka I'll take this you're gonna
need a dash of removal sports sports
drink and always remember to share I'm
saying I'm setting it they put a bowl
lighters in the center of the table it's
a conversation piece and it helps people
smoke now that we've got our table set
let's take a look at our entree oh my
word that looks almost good enough to
eat no matter what kind of deal you're
trying to seal tonight get ready to boil
there's gay this means a lot to me and
you're [ __ ] me hard on I'll [ __ ] you
all day if I want as you can see
sometimes things get a little heated in
the kitchen tip mxo the important thing
to always remember when you're cooking
with man style is maybe get some fresh
air of a big glass of water
okay bye